now in other news today this is
interesting and online abortion service
could offer women a safer way of ending
pregnancies now researchers in America
at the University of Texas to be exact
have analyzed data from a thousand women
in Northern Ireland and the Republic and
they have found that almost 95 percent
reported successfully ending their
pregnancy without having to have surgery
92 women that's 9.2 percent reported
experiencing symptoms for which they
were advised to get medical attention
and oh please nearly all of them 87 of
the 92 received medical help was reading
us now is the founder and director of
the abortion support network Marek lager
morning to you Maura good mind and now
why do people go online to get
medication to carry out an abortion
rather than visiting a doctor and going
through a procedure well we're talking
about Northern Ireland and the Republic
of Ireland where abortion is completely
against the law so their option is to
either raise four hundred to two
thousand pound to travel to England to
pay privately for a termination or they
can continue a pregnancy that they don't
want or they can go to a reputable
provider of online pills now these pills
are not a new thing they've been around
for over 10 years and they are on the
world's health organisations essential
medicines list so this study is showing
what we knew which is online these pills
are safe as long as you get them from a
reputable provider and follow the
instructions they cause a miscarriage
and the pills are safer than viagra and
and safer than aspirin
it's not always easy though is it to
tell which websites are genuine and
which websites are the good news well
that is that is a concern there's two
reputable organizations one is women on
web and that's that's what this study
was from was a thousand women who
accessed pills from women on web the
other is women health dot o-r-g so those
are the two reputable places and people
contact us a lot you know the people do
who don't have the money to travel over
by themselves and the other thing that's
important to note I saw the picture that
they put was of a giant Lea pregnant
woman and actually these pills are only
used up until nine or ten weeks
station so it's quite early in pregnancy
and obviously as you said this really
does apply to women in Northern Ireland
and the Republic but they miss out on
the aftercare don't know because often
it's said that that is very important
after an abortion how can they receive
help support advice
well again the British pregnancy
advisory service which is one of the
major providers here last year launched
a helpline so that any woman in Ireland
or Northern Ireland or the Isle of Man
where abortions also against the law and
can contact and get advice from a nurse
but the thing to understand is that
these pills are very safe these are the
same pills that you or I would take if
we went into a clinic here and got them
on the NHS and also there are family
planning agencies in the north and south
of Ireland where you can go for
aftercare for a termination but then of
course you have the issue of having to
lie and and about the fact that you
purchase pills against the law and in
Northern Ireland in fact I've now
started criminally prosecuting women for
taking these medications which again any
other woman in the United Kingdom could
get for free on the NHS I guess they do
have there is also an issue is in there
that about women not having advice
before taking them and what do you say
to women who might be watching this now
and thinking actually this could be a
possibility for me but it's a difficult
thing to do is maybe if you don't really
have anyone that you can talk to about
it
well it's what's really wonderful about
the internet and the modern world is
that you can you can contact any local
Family Planning agency if you're a young
person you can contact brooke if you are
older you can contact and british
pregnancy advisory service or Mary
Stopes if you're in Ireland and Northern
Ireland there's the Irish family
planning a new dais anonymously and in
an environment well in the Republic of
Ireland unfortunately the law says that
to get information about abortion you
have to do so in person so then they
make it extra complicated but the great
news about women on web and women help
women is that they have this an enormous
amount of information online
and you can send in an email and you can
have an email discussion with somebody
and there really are a lot of places
where you can you can be sent and for me
that the bigger thing is while these
pills are great you know it's fantastic
that you can take a pill at home instead
of having to you know fly to fly to
England and spend a lot of money for me
this is this is it's a plasterer yeah so
abortions against the law so if you have
internet access and you know about these
pills you can get them and you're under
nine weeks pregnant or if you're over
nine weeks pregnant and you have money
or you know about my organization and we
can help you financially but really what
we need is law reform yeah I'm going to
say you know essentially they are
writing the law and Mark Clark thank you
very interesting to speak to you about
about very difficult topic mara Clarke
there from the abortion support network
thank you thank you for having me